that's the stunt guy there you see and
you can tell because he's doing typical
stuntman acting
what he should have done was hit the
floor
rolled and then started to get up but he
puts he puts an extra stuntman role in
you see that
the overacting extra stuntman role you
know
bless him hi i'm
scott adkins and this is my fight
breakdown for legacy of lies
this fight is choreographed by my go-to
fight coordinator a guy called tim man
incredible martial artist himself one of
the best kickers you'll ever see
and the reason i love to work with tim
is because
not only does he choreograph it but he
understands how to shoot it
you see you could have the best
choreography in the world but if you
don't see it
you don't if you're not able to see each
technique and what's happening and you
don't understand the geography
of what's happening and maybe you're
shaking the camera around
the choreography is not going to be
worth anything he thinks in terms of
oh how can i show this with the camera
and how can i use the camera to
complement the fighting as well
this particular fight we didn't want it
to look
very martial arty we wanted it to be
very realistic
we did want it to look like a jason
bourne type of fight
but the difference is we wanted to film
it in a way that
you could really see the choreography in
terms of the fights in the bourne films
they're just shaking the camera and they
don't know what they're filming and they
they said well we'll edit that mess in
the editing room and
hopefully we'll have some semblance of
some sort of fight
it was in the born ultimatum and i did a
fight
and we were never told which camera to
sell a punch to
and there were about five cameras and he
didn't even know where the cameras were
so he's like well am i selling this
punch for this camera or this camera or
this camera which which camera i'm
selling the punch for
and you know that's not a safe way to do
it you know i can't make the punch work
for every camera unless i actually punch
matt damon in the face and you don't
want to do that do you
but um i know jeff imada uh was one of
the choreographers for the bourne films
and he's got a g condo
background so that was sort of flavor
that we wanted a very realistic sort of
almost a street fight but with less
about the hooks
and normal uh punches and more like with
the trappings and some karate chops
things like that just to give it that
sort of secret agent feel
but we wanted to feature the
choreography
so that you could always see exactly
what's going on
um but we didn't want to have long drawn
out shots like what you would see in a
john wick movie
or a tony jar film where it was very
wide
or a bruce lee movie where the camera
was just there and you would see bruce
doing his stuff in long takes
we wanted to have the feel of the bourne
film but
you can see what's going on not just
hear it but you can see it as well
the guy i'm fighting the actor's name is
leon sewer
he was a last-minute replacement we had
another guy
set to play this part and he dropped out
the last minute so
leon came in and saved our butts to be
honest it's not easy making these sorts
of sequences
i believe we shot over two days maybe
half a day each day so it's about a day
the director will go looking for
a place to shoot this sequence and he'll
be looking at
what it looks like through the lens you
know how's the lighting going to work
rarely did they really think about what
it's going to be like to perform stunts
on
that floor was just hard concrete no
giving it whatsoever
and it was dusty
there was dust everywhere we were
completely covered in dust as soon as we
hit the ground
and we were inhaling it all the time it
was
actually quite miserable and it was a
night shoot
so that made it even worse
this was a real keyboard they had the
real keyboard
and then they had the prop version that
was the breakaway keyboard
and i think that the the prop version it
was just way too flimsy i mean
you'd swing it and it would like bend in
the wind so that wasn't we knew that
wasn't working straight away so then
they had a maybe two or three keyboards
and the first
take with that that keyboard when i hit
him with it and he blocked it it just
completely shattered
i remember all the little keys just
flying around everywhere
and um we needed to do the shot again
and i remember somebody saying
we've only got two more keyboards so
okay we better get the shot then we're
gonna make this one count
and that's that's what it's all about
the fight scene this this sequence here
you don't want the camera so wide that
it's kind of a boring
shot you want to try and fill the frame
obviously because it's cinemascope
it's a very wide frame um but we don't
want to be so wide to see the whole body
that it's a boring shot
so midsection up you can see both of us
and then the cameraman which was also a
director of photography
simon rowling's he needs to be thinking
on the same level as the stunt
performers what the actors in this case
he needs to know the choreography as
well as we know it so that he knows that
it's an elbow there
and then i need to pan down and i need
to feature the knee
as he punches my knee and then it's a
punch to the body
and i've worked with some camera guys in
the past
and they just can't get on top of the
choreography they can't follow it
they're not fast enough they don't have
an agile enough mind to to think like a
stunt person does
but that's what you want to try and do
is follow the choreography
like that and make it interesting to
look at and i have to say that my little
block here
is very slick bang moving fast there
i've impressed myself
i mean all the fight is me but if i'm
getting thrown to the floor
and landing on the hard floor or
smashing through a table
you know generally you're going to bring
the stuntmen in because that's when
something could go wrong and you could
like you know break something and then
the whole film is going to shut down and
that's the end of it you know and for a
film like this we don't have a massive
budget
and we don't have enough days so it's
not like we can all wait for me to
repair
and then we'll complete the fight so
generally on every movie i do i'll get
some sort of injury
you're always kind of looking at wounds
of some sort of injury
so if it's a big stunt like getting
thrown onto your back
especially on this floor um i'll let the
stuntman
step in and do it that's the smart way i
did a movie
called avengement where i get smashed
through this bar
and then we smash through this other bar
and because it was the last day of
shooting i said okay i'll do it myself
because you know it didn't matter if i
had to go to the hospital so in that
instance i decided to do it myself
but to be safe for the producers we'll
let the stunt guy step in sometimes
these punches when it's like a profile
angle like that
they're always a bit of a difficult one
to make work see it has to be
um right in the correct spot if he was a
little bit too deep it wouldn't have
worked
and obviously if he was too far out he
would have been a mess
so he's got it in the perfect spot there
normally when i'm throwing an elbow what
i don't want to do is i don't want to
hit him with this bit
if he if he's behind me i want to try
and hit him if i am going to hit him i
don't want to hit him but if i did hit
him with this part of my
tricep it wouldn't be a big deal you
know what i mean it's nice and fleshy
it's going to be nice and comfortable
for him but if i hit him with the tip
here that's not going to be good i made
that mistake in in one film i hit a
stunt man
with the with my elbow properly and i
fractured his orbital
very unfortunate you're not trying to
hit them hit him in the face but if i
did
it would be with this bit
the styles of martial art in this fight
it is a bit of a melting pot
you've got like obviously you've got
your boxing
and party or kickboxing
i mean there is some karate chops from
leon's character
he is from a japanese heritage so i
think we felt like we'll put
maybe he's a karate guy and we'll put
some karate chops in there you know give
it a bit of that flavor
there's definitely some some trapping in
there which you know
you would have in wing chun and some
filipino martial arts so i'm
blocking and hitting at the same time or
i'm trapping his arm
and then he's trapping me and it's a bit
of a wing chun type thing going on
um or g condo that sort of thing there's
some judo there's some
uh japanese jiu jitsu there's not not
any aikido but there was a
similar move to it to an aikido moving
there i think
secret agent that's what i like to call
it
jake's up martin okay thanks for
watching
make sure you check out legacy of lies
available on
fandango now
you